[Musik]
liebe hörerinnen und hörer mit seinem
roman bauer haus gelangen boxberg 2015
der durchbruch mehrere wochen stand er
auf der bestsellerliste und da wurde
verfilmt und für die bühne adaptiert
serpentinen seien deutlich düsterer
nachfolger stand im jahr 2020 auf der
shortlist für den deutschen buchpreis
das ist davor einen ersten roman gegeben
hat den kaum jemand kennt das wissen
viele nicht das wird sich wohl bald
ändern denn dieser debüt roman mit dem
titel deadline erschien gerade in einer
neuausgabe im kanon verlag darum geht es
heute bei uns im podcast danach haben
wir ein neues literatur hetzel in petto
deadline erzählt von der technischen
übersetzerin paula die in allen
situationen um den richtigen den
präzisen ausdruck bringt von ihrer
heimkehr in das dorf ihrer kindheit in
dem die schwester bis heute auch wohnt
und erzählt von den familien dingen die
man zwar irgendwie bürokratisch
erledigen kann die man aber nie wirklich
los wird nun kehrt buchberg zwar nicht
ganz in die kindheit zurück aber
immerhin zu seinem ersten roman der auch
schon 13 jahre alt ist darüber möchten
wir mit ihm reden und er ist uns aus
berlin zugeschaltet hallo boxberg schön
dass du dabei bist
schön dass auch du dabei bist andreas
graf jetzt ein paar folgen ohne dich
urlaubsbedingt ferienbedingt und das ist
einfach viel viel besser zu dritt
wer ein gebrauchtes exemplar der ersten
deadline ausgabe aus dem mitteldeutschen
verlag damals kaufen möchte heute der
hat glück war dass unter 100 euro
bekommt das buch hat eine fast schon
dramatische geschichte denn die auflage
4 bis auf wenige exemplare einem lager
brand zum opfer
doch biaggi war das damals und wie geht
man als autor mit einem solchen unglück
um ich habe das ja
nicht gleich mitgekommen ehrlich gesagt
wäre das buch es 2008 erschienen es ist
ein bisschen besprochen worden und eine
handvoll exemplare sind verkauft worden
und
ich habe er
nach dem brand zufällig genau wie
mitbekommen dass da diese lage brand ich
glaube ich habe von freunden wir dass es
das dass die backlist dass verbrecher
verlag werde sich in flammen aufgegangen
war und auch von anderen kleinen
verlagen und dann dachte ich jetzt kommt
normal ob das haus damit er seinen
verlag auch betroffen ist will ich
unbedingt ein buch auch
mit verbrannte für die gäste unser
wasser noch und und nachdem nachdem das
tuch den indianern zwangsläufig nicht
mehr lieferbar war sind die rechten
nicht zurückgefallen und
und dann kann genauer haus raus und mein
erster roman der
kleinwagen - angerückt weil halt nur 200
leute das buch gekauft haben und
wahrscheinlich noch einige risse hilfen
vermuten
und von daher habe ich von dem brand
selber gar nicht gar nicht sofort
mitbekommen sondern erst später
aber das ist das natürlich der
dramatische sache für vor allem für für
für
die für kleinverlage die davon betroffen
waren war halt wenn halt tatsächlich
viele bücher
einfach glück finden aber jetzt ist es
natürlich auch für einen autor eine
dramatische geschichte soweit ich weiß
war deadline ja dein
abschlussprojekt in der leib beim
leipziger literaturstudium und man setzt
ja wahrscheinlich als autor doch auch
ein paar hoffnungen in so ein
erstlingswerk rein nämlich weil an und
plötzlich ist das halb komplett weg
ja es war meine meine diplomarbeit am
institut es stimmt aber
dass mit den hoffnungen das hat sich zum
zeitpunkt des brandes ohnehin längst
zerschlagen
das buch war weiß ich nicht zwei jahre
bestimmt auch markt und und das
interesse wie gesagt war war war eher
mäßig was zum teil ja auch meine zum
teil ja auch die die die absicht der atx
geschrieben habe dass ich so ein
bisschen
stilistisch gegen zum literaturbetrieb
schreiben wollte der der die gehobene
unterhaltungsliteratur ständig auf sein
hohes ziel gibt
und
dieses dieses vorhaben dagegen so ein
bisschen an zu stinken es mir viel
besser gelungen als geht eigentlich
wollte nämlich
ein praktisch gar nicht für das profil
passiert hat und wo er war war der
fast schon
für mich selber auch erledigt es kapitel
eigentlich als dann diese lager brand
kam ist heute dann es wurde dann wieder
merkwürdig als ein haus kam und
praktisch mit den ersten euphorischen
rezensionen ich das buch gebraucht
gesehen habe im netz für für 200 300 400
euro da dachte ich okay
das ist jetzt das ist jetzt richtig blöd
weil es gibt leute die das buch gelesen
interessiert sich dafür es ist aber
nicht da oder halt nur zu irgendwelchen
fantasiepreisen
antiquarisch erhältlich und zu dem
zeitpunkt waren die rechte dann aber
schon an dich zurückgefallen die waren
schon ähnlich zurückgefallen genau und
und es standen auch sehr früh zur
debatte oder ordentlich versteuert
relativ bald debatte ob
man das noch mal ob man das normale
aufgelegt also
dass pinkelte dann mit meinem verleger
so ein bisschen durch die verlage diese
idee
erzählt peter maske auch bei meinem
verleger ist ein zu wohlstand und es ja
jetzt der der verleger von kanon und
das findet ihr die idee das buch
herauszubringen mit kreativer gießen mit
und jetzt die amerikanerin erschien also
ich wollte unbedingt das erscheint weil
weil das ist dann natürlich tatsächlich
unbefriedigend wenn du wenn du mich auf
einmal leute für dich interessieren und
ein buch ist nicht da und es wie ich
vorhin gesagt hat mehrere nun gerücht
das ist einfach saublöd und und deshalb
bin ich auch sehr froh dass jetzt mal
neu erschienenes
denkt man bei so einem
13 jahre alten buch das es ja praktisch
schon fast in ein anderes leben ein
anderes ich was da geschrieben hat denkt
man da nicht stellenweise auch jedes das
würde ich heute vielleicht anders machen
oder das ist jetzt fast ein bisschen
nicht so gut oder er hat man da keine
zweifel
doch große
also ich hatte die zumindest
und dachte man kann den ganzen die
ganzen ästhetischen ansatz
heute gar nicht mehr richtig
also man muss ja sehen wie einbetten in
eine art keine ahnung historisierendes
nachwort oder so dachte ich
ich habe mir dann aber
das buch noch mal vorgenommen vor allem
dass das hörbuch auch nochmal noch mal
angehört und als verletzlich idol
klingen aber ich war dann sehr sehr
erstaunt wie
gut der text tatsächlich gealtert ist
ich hatte nicht damit gerechnet ich
dachte das kommt jetzt raus als so eine
art
dokument das ist das versteht er später
ausgeschrieben hat als erstes
geschrieben hat hier guckt euch mal an
aber meiner ansicht nach ist der text
der text tatsächlich
immer noch bestehen sondern dass das
fand ich selber sehr natürlich sehr
erfreulich auch dass diese erkenntnis
dass haben ihn nur wie die leute zu mir
gesagt das buch gelesen haben aber wie
das dann ist diese art von logen und
glaubt halten es gab dann zwei verdacht
sagt man dass wir gealtert sein könnte
entweder der text oder daneben der der
lesende es wieder lesende autor 13 jahre
später und beides hat sich nicht
umgesetzt beides beide haben sich nicht
bewahrheitet das ist ja interessant
ja
es ist
es ist ein bisschen unangenehm will ich
will ich dazu drüber reden muss aber
aber ab und
was mich erstaunt hat war tatsächlich
als ich das gehört habe
die 43 von dieser rhythmus der hinter
dem der text auch nach auch nach 13
jahren immer noch hat und dass das immer
noch funktioniert dass man nicht ja
nicht ja sich gelangweilt ab wendet also
ich jedenfalls und ich bin sehr schnell
gelangweilt von meinen eigenen sachen
ich war erstaunt wie viel wie viel von
dem was später in
genau aus vor allem aber ist er mit
ihnen könne es da schon angelegt ist in
lettland da war ich sehr erstaunt aber
gut das ist haben sie hat sozusagen die
blickwinkel blickwinkel geändert im
laufe der im laufe meines eigenen leben
eine kleinigkeit so konnte ich dem
nachwort entnehmen hast du allerdings
geändert
in diesem buch und
zwar hast du einmal das ausgeschriebene
antwort durch einen n-wort also endpunkt
glaube ich ersetzt
ja also dass das war dann etwas was
dann doch irgendwie die sensibilität des
heutigen of berg ich da doch nicht mehr
bestanden hat
genauso war es also ich hab ich bin
richtig geschockt als ich
das ausgesprochene antwort mehrfach
ausgesprochen
auf dem alten hörbuch und gehört habt
letztlich verlässt er unvermittelt kommt
und es gibt heute wie damals
natürlich nicht einwandfrei sozialen
erzählt theoretische erklärungen dafür
dass das wort da verbindet wird die
protagonistin da denkt daran wie ihre
mutter zu diesem mann den sie dass sie
denn sagen würde und wie ihre mutter
dann sagen hochelten das darf man sagen
usw
und in diesen den bewusstseinsstrom der
der ich erzählerin
hat es eine gewisse legitimität dass das
in wort
ausgeschrieben bzw ausgesprochen wird
tatsächlich ist es aber so dass es dass
es wenn du das heute in dem text drin
hast ist ein
solcher tabubruch es und eine solche
zitiert auch es signalisiert auch so
eine so eine brutalität wir alles aus
der vorrunde nach im text steht
überschreitet und das auch das wollte
ich habe mit vielen leuten mit vielen
leuten darüber gesprochen und und
praktische alle haben gesagt also auch
durchaus sehr für das thema
sensibilisiert die leute haben zu mir
gesagt nee das ist doch aus dem kontext
völlig klar dass das dass das weder der
autor ist der das wort hier verwendet
noch nicht mal die protagonistin sollen
die protagonistin legt das sozusagen in
gedanken ihrer mutter in den mund und
das ist doch legitim dass green zu
lassen
kamen aus der rein theoretischen sich
trotzdem ist ist so dieser paukenschlag
der mit diesem wort verbunden jetzt
dieses dieses riskieren das kriegt man
da einfach nicht weg und
und deshalb habe ich mich entschieden
ist dass im gedruckten text zu ändern
aber auch tatsächlich
janssen auch in der in der
aktualisierten hörbuchfassung geändert
die hauptfiguren der erzählerin paula
diaz übersetzerin und sie hat die macke
haben wir gerade gehört stets um den
bestmöglichen und präzisesten begriff zu
bringen dadurch bekommt der ganze roman
etwas sprach spielerisches etwas
experimentelles dass man so by our house
oder den serpentinen nicht findet die ja
ja so geradeaus erzählt sind
wie sie ist da die literarische
entwicklung interessieren dich sprach
experimente erzählerisch nicht mehr so
das hast du dich davon abgewandt etwas
neuem zugewandt wie würdest du das im
rückblick beschreiben ich habe mich
damals sehr mit ja mit somit somit zur
technischen sprachspielereien
beschäftigt die dann zum teil auch in
den
kleinen in den romanen eingeflossen sind
habe auch viele
versuche unternommen mit suchmaschinen
geschützt suchmaschinen gestützte lyrik
und und fand das sehr reizvoll es hat
dann so ein bisschen den reiz verloren
vor allem was diese diese suchmaschinen
gestützte diese suchmaschine zu
schreiben angeht weil ich weil ich
sozusagen an meine eigenen die grenzen
meiner eigenen technischen fähigkeiten
gelangt bin ich hatte irgendwann ich war
so an den punkt an dem ich eigentlich
hätte anfangen müssen generatoren zu
programmieren und sonst ich habe noch
ein paar muss ein paar ganz kurze sachen
gemacht auch dialogische sachen aus
tagesaktuellen oder die aktuellen
nachrichten schnipseln die ich dann auch
verschiedene figuren verteilt hat und
die dann von dem von dem text to speech
programm
sprechen lassen so dass ich zu ganz
kurze
theaterstücke sozusagen dann sogar
geschrieben habe geschrieben kann man
geschrieben kann man dann gerne erfasst
was gar nicht mehr nennen und das war
das was er für mich der punkt meiner
fähigkeiten hätte dann tatsächlich viel
mehr mit der mit der technik und dem
programmieren und sowas beschäftigen sie
um auf diesem wege weiter zu gehen
generell ist
sprachspiel also auch so wie es bei
bisschen deadline hat auch eine rolle
spielt ist es dieses mehrere begriffe
nebeneinander stehen zu lassen generell
ist das schon was das nicht sehr
interessiert und jetzt
aber halt auch klar das ist dass es für
viele leute die
denen da der vielleicht auch dieses jahr
nicht zu den spielerischen zugang dazu
haben es ist für die die rezeptions
erschwert und und mann reduziert er
natürlich sein potenzielles publikum
sehr stark
ich will aber überhaupt nicht
ausschließen dass dass ich irgendwann
wieder in der richtung in der richtung
was schreibe es ist halt
im moment ist es halt nicht so und
wie gesagt ich wüsste im moment auch
nicht so richtig wo es hingehen sollte
ich habe dabei mit lang versucht
sozusagen zu der art der malerei der
kubismus
auf die auf die begriffe
ich blicke aus verschiedenen richtungen
zu werfen und das im text darzustellen
das hat mich da gereizt
und wer weiß ob ich nicht mal wieder so
was machen das ist überhaupt nicht
ausgeschlossen
120 dass am ende des interesses sondern
das ende der technischen
fähigkeiten erst einmal
ja auch und dazu kommt natürlich ganz
stark also wenn man wenn man heute heute
irgendetwas also ich war damals so lange
zeit relativ naiv begeistert von dem
internet als gigantischen textkorpus
riesiges
derart riesige
bibliothek mit mit wörtern und sätzen
und texten drin mit der man spielen
konnte und die sofort zugänglich war
über suchmaschinen
diese dieser
völlig eigentlich ganz fertig aber doch
ziemlich naiv
zugang
verbietet sich natürlich sei der trotz
lauten
seit man weiß
dass das netz es gab ja immer schon die
vermutung auch schon vor auch schon vor
20 jahren aber mit 1000 heute ist
irgendwann fest und bewiesen und in
einem ausmaß bewiesen dass sich niemand
vorstellen können
dass das dass das netz eben auch eine
gigantische überwachungs maschinerie ist
und in dieser überwachungs maschinerie
angelegt auch eine auch eine
tötungsmaschine
di di di di di thronen die die jemen
oder in oder in waziristan leute
umbringen
sie sind ohne das internet nicht denkbar
und von daher hat es hat das netz
ziemlich
verloren und das wäre natürlich ein
aspekt den man wenn man heutzutage in
der richtigen irgendwas machen wollte
reflektieren oder sogar im vordergrund
stellen müssen
ich muss das ja jetzt natürlich fragen
weil wir haben ja beide in diesem sehr
sehr frühen internet angefangen zu
schreiben
buff du hattest ein and will block ich
hatte auch 1 es ist sehr sehr sehr lange
her wir haben damals irgendwie so vor
uns hin geschrieben und vor uns hin
geblockt und das war noch eine sehr sehr
unschuldige zeit hat dir dieses blog
dieses schreiben im internet das
regelmäßige schreiben hat wie würdest du
das heute einordnen ist das so waren das
so früh lockerungsübungen oder hat er
das schon irgendwie
passt sich ästhetisch ausprobiert oder
was für eine wie wichtig war das für
dich
es war in dem moment als die ersten wird
doch da waren die man einfach benutzen
konnte die menschen verlieren musste ja
und romantisch technisch keine große
ahnung haben mussten sie leben wo man
also
sofort ins internet schreiben konnte
ohne größere hürden
war das für mich
wir sind
also
[Musik]
auch dann zu sehen da gibt es andere
leute die man das auch und auch auch die
zu lesen und zu merken dann wird von den
gewesen
und dann habe ich das ein bisschen
herumprobiert ja das war ich
empfinde es aus heutiger sicht als als
als extrem frei jetzt etwas was das
schreiben an gilt
natürlich natürlich ich hatte damals
auch noch keine familie ich hatte ja
auch mehr ich hatte ja auch mehr zeit um
das zu machen aber um überhaupt mehr
zeit um sozusagen wenig zielgerichtet
irgendwas das hört zu machen
und unser patient und da gab es ja eine
menge leute wie das versucht haben wie
du ja auch und und viele andere und
ausprobieren ja es war auch ne
ausprobieren aber ich habe ich ja auch
auf den leser medellín ausprobiert und
so also ich habe ich verschiedene
verschiedene spielbare sozusagen
wobei bei den lesebühnen ist es ja immer
schon ein bisschen auf den effekt auch
hinschreiben nada will man ja den gag
man will ja den applaus vielleicht auch
ein bisschen aber man schreibt ja
tatsächlich auf ein anwesen das publikum
hin und will von denen eine reaktion das
war ja bei den blocks an zb weniger der
fall
ist das blog dann vielleicht auch so ein
bisschen ein zwischending zwischen die
lesebühnen und dann dem was man
vielleicht als das literarische
schreiben in anführungszeichen
bezeichnen könnte
dann bin ich nämlich sicher weil auch
weil auch blog tech serben werden unter
bestimmten bedingungen veröffentlicht an
die man sich bisher verhält weil sonst
man gar nicht gelesen und da er selbst
da geht es nicht unbedingt um gedichte
aber es geht dann doch auch um so was
wie
interessant das ist sozusagen
die du ja schon auch erfüllen solltest
wenn du einen blog und du darfst nicht
zu lang schreiben weil weil sonst
nach einem halben meter scrollen die
gutwilligen alte auch
was was was aber dass das verbindende es
ist tatsächlich diese völlige freiheit
wie du eine lesebühne vor allem wenn du
ihn jetzt nicht als gast bei einer
fremden lese willi bist du jetzt deine
eigene ist ein paar leuten zusammen auf
die beine gestellt hat und diese völlige
freiheit machen zu können auf der bühne
was du willst und jetzt dem blog halt
auch da es gibt keinen kein keine regie
keine kleine redaktion kann sonst was
wir da rein und
es bleibt dabei sie ist dann doch wieder
hier bei der gemeinsamkeit von lese bin
und blogs diese freiheit ist schon was
tolles einfach
lass uns noch mal ein schritt zurück zum
buch kehren
mir fällt auf dass es nur wenige
männliche autoren gibt die eine
weibliche ich erzählerin wellen hast du
gemacht jetzt mit deadline was glaubst
du woran das grundsätzlich liegt und war
das sind irgendeiner weise schwierig in
paulas haut zu schlüpfen oder war das
ein ganz selbstverständlicher schritt
ganz naheliegend arbeit
als er kippte es gibt tatsächlich selten
in einem buch das ich sehr dass ich sehr
sehr schätze
es ist auch so bei christoph hein der
fremde freund ist auch die weibliche
täterin
bei deadline hatte es einfach bin
hatte es ganz schlicht zunächst den
grund ich wollte die figur in gewisser
weise möglichst weit weg wegrücken von
mir sehr und auch von meiner auch von
meiner physiognomie
paula ist eine sehr übergewichtige frau
ich bin ein
fehler also ein ziemlich teurer mann und
das hat es mir geholfen wie sie diese
figur ist die figur von mir
die ich erzählerin ich perspektive von
von mir selber
wegzurücken
also das ist der
es war der allererste der allererste
ganze da kommt natürlich der gedanke
darf nur das machen kann man das machen
können
leute die keine frau aus in eine frau
aus der ich perspektive
erzählen lassen so ich dachte bisher
überlegt kann ich dafür ja ja klar dass
schon jetzt eine direkte frage
andererseits andererseits ist sozusagen
die die prototypische erzähle figur egal
wer werden buch schreibt oder ein roman
schreibt seit seit hunderten von jahren
man
also wenn du wenn du ne ich erzähle aus
wenn du was aus der ich-perspektive
dienste nimmst du auch fast automatisch
an aus als wenn vorher ganz klare andere
zeichen gesetzt nun ist auch heute noch
fast automatisch an dass man sie kennt
und
ich dachte was soll das muss ja nicht
ewig so bleiben
und dann stehen natürlich die frage gibt
es
gibt es aspekte die
die du als man nicht beschreiben kann
etwas
was die weibliche perspektive und die
ist stattlich die gibt es natürlich jede
menge live aspekte
allerdings ist es bei der paula der
geselligen ausklang der große vorteil
dass sie
ihr sohn ihr sony art homo faber sissi
ist
sie es nicht gerade nicht gerade das was
ich was ich
traditionelle frauenzeitschriften und
eine untypische frau vorstellen und sie
hält auch
alles mögliche von sich fern was was
jetzt
oder zumindest zeigt zuerst zeigte sich
sprachlich nicht was
was sie
berühren als oder als frau
[Musik]
angehen könnte und von daher dass das so
das ist eigentlich glaube ich so einen
großen unterschied macht ob die
schülerin
auch die fähigkeit steckt oder oder oder
man
2 zu sehen weil sie einfach in relativ
technokratischen blick auf die stetig
auf die welt hat ich werde sie
eigentlich ehrlich gesagt genau deswegen
ziemlich glaubwürdig weil mich ja auch
nicht jede meiner gedanken voran setzte
ich als frau denke jetzt ist die technik
steht nicht oder so also man denkt das
ja erst mal so als menschen
deswegen fand ich paulas effekte
eigentlich komplett
nachvollziehbar und verständlich und es
gibt am anfang so einen kurzen
irritationen moment wo man versteht ach
mensch ja es ist noch eine frau obwohl
der freundin man drauf steht auf dem
cover aber so aber danach habe ich es
eigentlich komplett vergessen genau wie
ich auch die sprachspielereien irgendwie
man man stolpert die ersten drei seiten
aber danach reiht sich das eigentlich
dann doch sehr organisch ein finde ich
so in den erzählfluss und dann bin ich
eigentlich auch mit paula und ihrem
tisch sehr gut mitgegangen
ich hoffe das geht anderen auch so und
ich hoffe das system dem buch auch dass
das buch auch diesmal etwas besser
wahrgenommen wird als im ersten anlauf
es erscheint ja im kanon verlag der name
ist jetzt vielen noch nicht ganz bekannt
dass es auch ein ganz neuer verlag ein
unabhängiger verlag
und du bist auch als mitgesellschafter
immer wieder auf diesen verlagsgruppen
bildern
abgebildet worden ich dachte ach mensch
guckt man da steht ja auch berger den
kennste so wie kamst du denn eigentlich
kann und beziehungsweise was was weißt
du darüber warum bist du da mit gegangen
und hast dich da auch gleich eingekauft
also es war ja so dass es vor allem kurz
angedeutet dass gunners in meine
damalige pflege beim aufbau der der
das manuskript auf den fisch gekriegt
hat und als einziger von zehn oder
zwanzig verlegern gesagt ja das will ich
machen
das ganze
haus eben gemacht hat bei aufbau
beziehungsweise verklungen war dann von
aufbau weggegangen ist zurück stein ich
bin die zu steigern dann
wird er auch beruf stein aufzuarbeiten
und hat sich über etwas was wir jetzt
eigentlich machen kann dann
johnson in der zeit immer wieder darüber
unterhalten was ein kleines interaktion
irgendwann kamen mit der dinge anzeigen
verlages und
politaktivist
das ist schon ein
ziemliches warten
also gerade auch in der in der zeit
aktion so zu sagen es war klar die
schlaks gelungen stellt in dieser zeit
wo corona auf die wirkung ist wo die
buchläden zum großen teil in deutschland
geschlossen sind
man muss eigentlich ein wahnsinnig sein
und in der zeit verlag könnten zu rollen
und
gab dann aber wieder die dritte
gesprochen und er hat nicht und einige
andere dann auch auch gefragt ob
wir dann ist mitgesellschafter werden
werden wollen
ich wollte sehen jetzt an geld gefehlt
hätte sondern weil er weil er so zu
sagen
freunde
als berater dann mit dabei haben wollte
und ich fand das sehr schmeichelhaft und
und hat ja auch große lustig zu machen
und große lust es mit mit una und in
anderen leuten zusammen zu machen
und bin sehr glücklich auch mit den erst
möglich wenn die karte neben mir von
katharina erfolg war der termin und die
briefwechsel von lionel feininger und
der kleine waren die ersten teil und es
kommen noch zwei weitere in diesem
programm
was den titel angeht
die titel des verlags den namen zu
langsam habe ich gesagt
dass ich weiß nicht wie das mit kriegs
diese große diskussion über kanon also
über den literarischen kanon im moment
die ja auch
sehr heftig wenn dann mit dem verlag ein
costa ricaner nein das ist doch ein es
ist doch
ich weiß nicht ob es so gut
ob das nicht anmaßen triebe kommen muss
und dann fasste er
das ist ja auch keine falten oder
literarische kann und sondern kann steht
für ihn vor allem für viel stimmung ist
kalt aber weil ich ein bisschen
geklettert die erklärung sei nicht
aufgekommen wäre in diesem kontext
geöffnet von büchern dass da jemand von
karner und spricht in vielstimmigkeit
meint und ließ mich dann aber so ein
bisschen davon überzeugt und achtet kann
und selbst
wenn sie einen verlag machen die ganze
welt wieder gemacht hat ist es ohnehin
egal wie der verlag konkret heißt dann
kommt auch die bücher an die der verlag
gemacht wird und wir haben ja diesen
diesen diesen affen noch als verlag
symbol der dann unter auf den umschlägen
unter diesen schriftzug alonso baumelt
und der rest dann auch so ein bisschen
irritiert und daher den titel eigentlich
auch ganz okay
muss ein schönes gefühl seiner nicht
stiller gesellschafter zu sein sondern
lauter gesellschafter genau sprechen da
mit denken planen da
sich ums programm kümmern da
wie kann man sich das genau vorstellen
und fand dann auch gut als als als gut
gemeint hat obwohl ich hoffentlich
deadline bei lokalen raus bringen wollen
weil gefangen ist er recht die
alternative wäre also es hätten sich
auch andere größere verlages
interessiert aber
aber mir ist völlig klar dass ein roman
wieder klein
[Musik]
ideales für einen großen
publikumsverlage und dass da die gefahr
dass das buch ein bisschen
stiefmütterlich behandelt wird oder
untergeht dann doch größer ist als wenn
es als uns jetzt als eines von fünf
büchern ersten programm des k9 verlag
erscheint unterwegs
sind die bücher auch toll gemacht also
die besitzen sehr aufwändig gestaltet
sehr ansprechend
hätte man so auch nicht unbedingt in
jede meldung verlag haben
und das schöne ist dass es jetzt nicht
mehr 100 200 300 400 euro kostet und
nur für bibliophile wahrscheinlich also
die können das dann ja immer noch dafür
ausgeben für dieses buch erreichbar ist
überhaupt sondern das deadline jetzt im
kanon verlag mit 176 seiten zum preis
von 22 euro zu haben ist
gefällt uns sehr
die bei postberg vielen vielen dank für
das gespräch auch das hat uns sehr
gefallen ich danke euch für die
gelegenheit zu erzählen
mitte august 2021 zeit für ein neues
literatur rätsel von tilman spreckelsen
seit zwei jahren nun schon erzählt uns
der kollege die geschichte eines
bekannten werks allerdings aus sicht
einer nebenfigur sie hören das gleiche
liebe hörerinnen und liebe hörer und
wenn sie dann eine ahnung haben wie
figur und werk heißen machen sie am
besten einfach mit in der juli folge war
es die böse königin und stiefmutter aus
schneewittchen unter den richtigen
einsendungen haben wir ein exemplar
verlost von olga force roman russisches
narrenschiff wie immer aus der anderen
bibliothek und auch wie immer vielen
dank an den verlag
auch allen teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmern unseren besten dank gewonnen
hat lars klinik aus sandhausen wir
gratulieren machen sie diesmal mit um
welches werk und welche figur soll es in
unserem neuen literatur rätsel gehen
dankbar ist meine rolle in dieser
geschichte nicht wer fragt auch nach
dankbarkeit gerade wenn es um die
heiligste aufgabe geht die das leben für
uns frauen bereit hält das formen junger
menschen zu nützlichen und kultivierten
wesen die sich in gesellschaft zu
bewegen wissen und ihren platz kennen
das sich damit beim einem schützling
gescheitert bin ist bitter aber die
schuld daran trifft mich nicht
vom ersten tag an als dieses andere ding
in unser haus kam war die sache verloren
wir waren auf einem guten weg mein
schützling und ich die bedauernswerte
körperliche schwäche des mädchens
hinderte uns nicht gemeinsam mit dem
großen werk voranzukommen
aber dann dieser wildfang
alles alles hat sie mir zerstört mit
ihrem toben nie hat sie gelernt wie man
sich in unserer stolzen stadt verhält
und das schlimmste ist sie hat den sinn
meines schützlings gegen mich gewendet
und am ende da auch den des mannes von
dem ich hoffen durfte einmal mehr als
nur seine angestellte zu sein aber
darüber
mein herz
haben sie eine ahnung wer da spricht und
aus welchem buch er oder sie erzählt
dann schicken sie uns ihre lösung bitte
bis zum 6 september 2021 an unsere e
mail adresse bücher - podcast faz.de
bücher mit auf unserer website
www.faz.net / bücher podcast auch hier
bücher mit finden sie die
teilnahmebedingungen der rechtsweg
soviel vorab ist ausgeschlossen
diesmal verlosen wir unter den richtigen
einsendungen ein exemplar der
musikalischen gemälde das ist eine
sammlung von fünf novellen von honoré de
balzac besten dank auch hier wieder der
andere bibliothek für diese preis
stiftung
die teilnahmebedingungen und die adresse
für die lösung des herzens finden sie
auf unserer seite faz.net / bücher mit -
podcast natürlich auch besprechungen
früherer bücher von oft wie sie uns
schreiben können wissen sie wie sie uns
licon oder abonnieren oder sternchen
geben können wenn sie wollen das wissen
sie auch in den pott ketzern ihres
vertrauens bei spotify oder auf
instagram da heißen wie red faz bücher
bücher mit für diesmal sagen mir vielen
dank fürs zuhören und bis dann bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]